neo is nearly bankrupt in the third
quarter of 2021 they burned 440 million
597 000 to keep operations afloat among
startups and especially ev startups such
atrocious net income figures are quite
common given the massive overhead
associated with manufacturing and
scaling up vehicle production
fortunately most of the high flying ev
startups have billions if not tens of
billions in the bank so they can
maintain such losses for dozens of
quarters or several years
the same however cannot be said about
neo given this alarming situation neo
went ahead and completed a share
offering to raise 2 billion in november
this has bought them a few more quarters
but completing share offerings in the
future is going to be significantly more
difficult given that their stock is down
80 percent from their all-time highs
last year considering all this
macroaccess gives neo a 96 probability
of bankruptcy so if neo doesn't figure
out profitability within the next couple
of quarters they could go bankrupt just
a year ago though neo was likely their
favorite eb stock on the market after
tesla so what happened to neil
taking a look back the story of neo
dates back to a chinese man named
william lee william was born on august
9th 1974 on a dairy farm in the antwe
province growing up william's family was
rather poor but they highly valued
education and wanted william to go to
college so they started saving up for
college as soon as william turned seven
years old as a kid william would often
live with his grandparents who lived in
the nearby ruling village this was
especially influential for william
because whenever he was with his
grandparents they gave him an accounting
task william was responsible for
counting money and keeping records of
all the cows that his grandfather sold
this experience didn't lead to some
insane revelation unlike william
figuring out the importance of money or
william learning the mechanics of
business but it did make it clear to
william that regardless of what he did
in the future he definitely did not want
to live the rest of his life in the
village herding cattle and keeping
records so william started focusing on
leaving the village and seeing the
outside world and his first major
opportunity to do so was of course
college william attended peaking
university in beijing which is actually
one of the most prestigious universities
in china
apparently it's the center of
humanity-based studies in china and is
often called the harvard of china
currently their acceptance rate sits at
a measly 0.91 percent so given that
william got accepted he clearly knew
what he was doing anyway william majored
in sociology and one of the first things
he did after enrolling was pick up a job
as a deputy monitor at the university
his responsibilities included leading
trips to historic places like the great
wall of china and helping his cohort
build teamwork skills william had no
complaints with the job but
unfortunately he would fall ill and be
hospitalized for a month and by the time
he recovered he lost the job this
experience made william realize how
dispensable he was and in an effort to
combat this he would try to add a few
specialties to his skill set this
included getting a minor in computer
science and the law soon enough william
graduated from college but he was still
as lost as ever before so he decided to
follow what interested him
one of william's biggest passions was
cars but william wasn't ready to do
anything nearly as ambitious as starting
up an eevee company so he gauged the
business landscape and the most obvious
opportunity he saw was the internet so
in 1996 william decided to combine his
passion for cars and the opportunity
that came with the internet in order to
find a precursor to bid auto today bit
auto has evolved into being one of the
largest automotive publications in china
and they do everything from marketing
consultations to providing transactional
services but back in 1996 bit auto was
basically just a blog and william was
the main reporter given the rapid growth
of the internet throughout the late
1990s and the lack of chinese automotive
content at the time william was able to
build up a solid following rather
quickly which allowed him to go from
barely making ends meet to being pretty
well off despite the evolution of his
finances though william had no urge to
stop being a reporter and take on a more
traditional role as a ceo he says that
being a reporter gave him insight into
the automotive industry that he couldn't
get anywhere else and it wasn't until
2000 that williams stepped back from
reporting and officially founded bit
auto holdings while william was
initially hesitant to make the move once
he made the move he was fully committed
he split the business up into three
segments which included the advertising
and subscription business the
transaction services business and the
digital marketing solutions business
starting with this advertising business
this is basically what he was already
doing he sold advertising spots on his
news portal to automakers dealerships
and insurance companies given that all
of you guys are watching youtube i'm
sure you all know how this works moving
on to their transactions business bit
auto partnered with the leading
automobile finance platform in china for
the yixing group limited to provide
various financial services to their
customers and finally in terms of the
digital marketing business given that
bit auto had achieved moderate success
on the internet williams started to
provide digital marketing consulting
services to automakers and dealerships
you know the classic how to set up a
website how to drive traffic to the site
how to convert viewers into customers
and so on and so forth william did this
for the next 13 years which not only
made him wealthy but gave him
significant connections within the
automotive world and this put him in the
perfect position to start up neo
being involved in the automotive world
for decades at this point it was clear
to william that evs were the future he
wasn't the only one that was convinced
of this future either basically all of
corporate china and the government were
confident that evs were the future and
given the pollution problem in china
they wanted to switch over as soon as
possible as a result when william
proposed the idea of founding an eb
startup dozens of high-flying tech
companies lined up to provide funding
this included tensioned xiaomi sequoia
capital lenovo temesec and tpg and with
that william founded neo in november of
2014 but it wasn't originally called a
neo initially the company didn't really
have a name and they were simply
referred to it as nextdv
anyway despite all this funding and the
involvement of big players the general
public had no clue what nextdb was given
that nextdb vehicles were consumer
vehicles this wasn't a good thing so
william's first order of business was to
generate hype around the brand and what
better way to do that than show off a
flashy sports car in november of 2016
next tv debuted the neo ep9 sports car
the car would actually become the most
expensive ev ever built clocking in at
3.48 million dollars the ep9 was also
the fastest ev ever built with a maximum
speed of 217 miles per hour despite the
impressive stats this car was obviously
not reasonable for the average person in
china but this didn't matter
nyo had no intentions of mass producing
this car
this was simply a publicity stunt like
the tesla roadster to generate hype and
that's exactly what it accomplished soon
enough people from around the world were
talking about newest crazy electric
sports car that could break 200 miles
per hour and this gave neo the perfect
opportunity to launch the luxury suv the
es-8 in late 2017. the es8 wasn't
exactly cheap but it also wasn't crazy
expensive either it started at 67 000
which made it comfortably affordable to
well-off families initially neo's
customers and car magazines loved the
es8 but unfortunately this didn't last
too long
you see it starting in late 2018 stories
of es-8s catching on fire start to
surface there were only a handful of
cases but as you would guess this was
terrible for nearest public reputation
neo would end up recalling the esi in
2019 and in the year's delivery numbers
would subsequently jump off a cliff in
late 2018 neo was delivering over 3000
es8s per month but by mid-2019 they were
delivering less than 500 es8s per month
neo tried to combat this decline by
launching a smaller suv called the es6
and this did help quite a bit especially
given the lower starting price but neo
was still in a pretty rough position
financially and reputation wise at the
end of 2019
out of nowhere though tesla would reveal
the cyber truck and tesla stock would go
to the moon and the rest is history
even though new stock was sent to the
moon along with tesla from a low of one
dollar to nearly 70
neo was far from safe due to three main
reasons starting with their investor
base
most of the people who invested in neo
did not invest because they were
confident in their financials or
optimistic about their future in most
cases they missed out on tesla and they
didn't want to buy into tesla at several
hundred dollars so they looked for the
next tesla and the most obvious choice
within the stock market was neo
considering this a significant portion
of neo's investors were short-term
investors who are looking to make a
quick buck so you can bet that these
guys left as soon as neo started to dip
substantially which has made it
significantly harder to do share
offerings and raise money and that
brings us into new second major problem
which is that they're not profitable nor
are they close to being profitable most
of tesla's run occurred right after
tesla achieved profitability after years
of struggling with model 3 production
in fact tesla needed bankruptcy on
several occasions while trying to ramp
up production
well i mean tesla really faced the
severe
uh threat of death uh due to the model 3
production ramp
essentially the company was bleeding
money like crazy and and just
if if we didn't solve these problems in
a very short period of time uh we would
die uh and it was extremely difficult
to solve them how close to death did you
come we are within
single budget weeks and this is exactly
where neo is at right now last year they
delivered 91 000 vehicles and over the
next few years they have to scale to
hundreds of thousands if we take a look
back at 2017 tesla delivered 103 000
cars and over the next few years they
scaled to hundreds of thousands which is
when they faced the vast majority of
their financial problems so there's no
doubt that the next few years will be
extremely difficult for neo given that
they're just now entering production
hell and finally moving on to the last
major factor weighing down neo we have
the chinese government now the chinese
government has no problems with neo
specifically in fact they're major
proponents of the eevee revolution
however they've been fighting a
corporate war against jack ma and the
listing were against the us for the past
18 months and all this uncertainty has
basically crashed the entire chinese
stock market in fact alibaba nearly
revisited ipo levels after dropping 76
percent from their all-time high so
antonio sheds all of its short-term
investors survived production hell and
the chinese government lightens up neo's
future remains uncertain
despite all this uncertainty personally
i don't think neo is going anywhere for
one reason which is the chinese
government while their actions thus far
have been inadvertently hurting neo i'm
rather confident that they won't let neo
go bankrupt for the ccp saving neo is
not only a matter of reducing pollution
within china but a matter of national
pride china really wants to beat the
rest of the world to evs and to be the
first world power to make the transition
and sacrificing one of their biggest ev
producers definitely won't help that
also we should note that the ccp has
helped neo in the past in late 2019 when
nia was facing the recall crisis the ccp
gave them a one billion dollar bailout
at the time neo's entire market cap was
hovering at just one to two billion
dollars so the ccp basically gave them a
loan that was the size of their market
cap today neo is worth over 30 billion
dollars even with the recent decline so
i think the ccp would be more willing
than ever to loan them a couple billion
if needed personally i wouldn't invest
in neo because i'd rather just invest in
tesla but with that being said given ccp
support i don't think neo is going
anywhere anytime soon despite the
horrendous balance sheet but that's just
what i think do you guys think neo will
go bankrupt comment that down below
also drop a like if you hope neo
survives and accelerates ev adoption and
of course consider checking out our
international channels to watch the
videos in other languages and consider
subscribing to see more questions
logically answered but until then i'm
hari and i'll see you guys on the next
one
[Music]